[Music]
see a Maori gives birth to baby number
two on Sunday the 39 year old quick-fix
star announced on Instagram that she and
hubby cory hardrict have welcomed their
second child a baby girl
they're already proud parents to 6 year
old son Cree curry is going to have a
baby sister
Tia captioned this gorgeous photo with
her newborn daughter quote born May 5th
at 10:29 a.m. at 6 pounds and 4 ounces
19 point 8 inches we are in heaven we
are so excited prior to her arrival
Corrie instagrammed this hospital snap
with the caption grown man tears baby
girl is near prayers up and on Friday
Tia revealed that she was ready to go
tweeting my hospital bag is packed and
we are in the homestretch ladies and
gents Maori and hard rekt just
celebrated their 10th wedding
anniversary in April and last year she
opened up to ET about this secret to
their marital success I think a lot of
people you know they have this
expectation going into marriage that
everything is going to be perfect there
are gonna be some days where I say
something that I don't necessarily mean
if I'm like you know annoyed or whatever
you know forgive him you forgive
yourself I think that's the key but also
I think appreciation and showing how
much you appreciate your significant
other
[Music]
[Applause]